this week on wheel of science we're
talking quantum physics
look at me neil i'm all entangled like
quantum like
no chuck you're just entangled
[Music]
welcome to wheel of science hey
everybody welcome to wheel of science
i'm chuck nice and of course
this is the show where we answer your
questions about the universe but i don't
answer your questions about the universe
the one
the only dr neil degrasse tyson
answers your questions about the
universe what's up neil
quantum physics that's not my expertise
i just know enough to get by in the
universe
so we'll try it we'll see we'll see how
it goes just enough quantum physics to
get by
huh well in that case let's spin that
wheel
indeed spin that wheel
[Music]
and hamed abdellalim wants to know this
what role does the higgs boson play in
quantum physics
actually you could have asked that
question about any particle the the
proton the neutron the
the electron neutrinos quarks
they are all subject the laws of the
quantum
actually so is the whole universe but
the smaller you are the more you
manifest these laws
and so the higgs boson it's a quantum
particle
and how does the higgs boson work it
makes a field and that field
grants mass to any particle that moves
through it
it's a badass particle if you have to be
a particle that would be the one to be
don't tell anybody but that's the one to
be
and you might ask how does it actually
assign mass
think of a hollywood party
if you go to a hollywood party and
nobody knows you you can just go
straight to the bar
like that you have low hollywood mass
if you are famous and you walk into the
party everyone gathers around you
they want your autograph they want to
take your picture and you're working
towards the bar
but you're moving really slow you have a
lot of inertia
slow inertia and you can't get through
the math you can't get through it
so you have high hearty mass
the hollywood party is exactly the higgs
field so
what party is it where you sit home and
lament your career
and cry what particle is that that's the
neutron
it has no charge so therefore it can
attract no one
did did you say the nice tron because
damn neil that's
that's kind of harsh bro that's rough
all right neal you ready for another
question spin that wheel
[Music]
tim ger says do two entangled particles
communicate faster than the speed of
light
i've heard it's apparently instant it
turns out
one of the rules of quantum physics is
that because particles are also waves
if there's a particle on this side of a
hill and it can't get across to the
other side
the wave function does exist
and actually exist in a little bit on
the other side of the hill
so the electron can disappear here and
reappear there
collapsing the wave function and the
electron would have moved from there to
there
instantly basically faster than the
speed of light
it's called quantum mechanical tunneling
and it happens all the time
and it is mysterious and beautiful so
what's the hype about tachyons then so
tachyon
is a hypothetical particle named for
being very fast tachios is
greek for speed the tachometer gets th
it's the same root
so a tachyon is a particle hypothetical
particle that exists
only faster than light and it can go to
infinitely high speeds and the slowest
you can ever get this thing to go
is the speed of light itself it turns
out
this is not violated in einstein's
equations because you're not crossing
the speed of light
you're coming into existence faster than
the speed of light and you put that into
the equations
it ends up living backwards in time this
is a backwards time traveling particle
hypothesized we've never discovered one
so we don't know if they really exist
they probably don't
but it's fun to talk about them because
they don't violate
einstein's relativity equations perhaps
the reason you don't find them is
because you're not looking for them in
1955 where you have to go back in time
and kiss your mother for
i mean don't kiss your mother i'm you
know what how about we take a break
okay we'll be back with more wheel of
science
[Music]
you know i love wix so much for
sponsoring wheel of science that i'm
gonna sing a song about them
i use wix to okay i'm not gonna do it
okay but for real it's almost 20 20 and
everyone is looking
at everything on their cell phones you
need your website to be perfect
on any mobile device and wix
automatically
formats everything from mobile even lets
you refine it for a perfect experience
how cool is that head to the link in the
description and start your site today
that's wix.com go slash star talk
[Music]
la la la okay welcome back to wheel of
science i'm chuck nice and of course
we're here with dr neil degrasse tyson
neil are you ready for another question
brady myers wants to know what
technology can be achieved
using quantum physics what you perhaps
don't know
is that there is no creation storage and
retrieval
of information in this information
technology revolution
without the exploitation of the quantum
the quantum is all around us it is in
your computers
it is in your storage chips it is in
your memory
it is in everything it is in the
electricity
around us and we did not do really
amazing things with electricity until we
understood how quantum
physics affected it so you want to ask
what can we do
with the quantum everything
damn all right neil is caption time of
course that's where we take a picture of
you and invite our people to give it a
caption and we got hundreds of responses
so you've seen them which one do you
like i think my favorite there
is i'm just trying to find the place
where it says that your opinion
is more important than scientific facts
it's snarky
as an educator that's not how you
interact with people but
that's not what caption contests are for
yeah well as a comedian
that's exactly how you interact with
people and by the way it may be the most
polite way
that you interact with people so good
job man
time now for our wheel of science poll
make sure that you answer the poll
right here and the question is would you
want to be a quantum superhero
like ant-man you know when i think of
being a superhero i don't think to
myself
how small can i make myself that's just
not a thing
although growing up as a kid i did want
to be
mighty mouse knowing that he was small
just because he sang
opera and saved the women in distress
while singing i just thought that was
that was kind of cool
and a big kind of chest like that and so
i wanted to be mighty mouse
but other than that i'm thinking i don't
i don't need i don't need to hang out
with quantum phenomena
i'm very good as a macroscopic object
thank you yeah well you know you're uh
you're you're in the mighty mouse i'm
more of an underdog
i mean that like not even the cartoon
character i'm talking about me
personally man
my life's a ret meal well there you have
it that is our show
as always we have to say thank you to dr
neil degrasse tyson thanks neil always
here for you chuck
you say that now but at three o'clock in
the morning where
are you where are you where i always am
at 3am
looking up at the stars oh god i'm gonna
puke
thanks to wix for sponsoring this
episode if i owned a vacation resort on
proxima centauri b
i would be telling people about my
website that i created on wix
unlimited fonts beautiful templates
search engine optimization
which does it all upgrade to a premium
plan to add things like
chat email member login and more head to
the link
in the description and start your site
today that's
slash wix.com top that's our show neil
until next time keep looking up
even when it's 3 a.m
[Music]
here i come to save the day